hey everybody i'm back with more chess
game
breakdowns from the amazing report
assessing game balance with alpha zero
exploring
different and new rules to chess it hit
the press
more than a few days ago at this point
from google's deep mind and we've been
bringing you
all the behind the scenes content we
prepared so
it's time for a video on the big the big
subject i rank the idea of stalemate
equaling a win
as my biggest takeaway it was number one
on my top 10 list click the video in the
notes below if you missed it
there's some things i think we should
consider from this report maybe
instituting and
why not let's have some more fun and get
more decisive results
now obviously the biggest con to
bringing bringing the fact that
stalemate would now equal a win
is that we'd lose moments like this from
idiots on the internet
who just simply apparently don't know
how to checkmate
up a rook and a bishop so yes if
stalemate equaled a win
we would no longer have moments like
that but as we know the internet is
full of idiots not sure who that guy was
doing crazy stuff so if you're into
watching people do dumb stuff
there's other things you can go watch on
the internet we don't need
checkmate to be a family anymore let
everybody have a win
with stalemate uh and with this video
i'm not gonna
just tell you why i think that's the
case but show you some positions that
would totally change
uh the game but also some things that
would have to totally change in the
approach by the world's best chess
players if stalemate equal to win so
without any further ado let's dive right
into why stalemate
should be a win so we start with the
basics right king and pawn endings we
learned this in the beginning of our
chess careers because if we know how to
win
with just a single extra pawn that gives
us
tons of empowerment in the rest of the
game now we value every piece
differently we we care about the tactics
we have this goal in our mind that all i
really need is a pawn to win
because if i get it up to the edge of
the board a queen's gonna help me check
me
the problem is that this particular
position with a more
active king just a single more active
king
from our opponent takes away all those
dreams all the dreams we have about a
single pawn helping us win a game
we get to positions like this and as i
press play that's not the case
right that means all of our hard work
the fact that just a single pawn
advantage that would allow us to outplay
our opponent for one trick
in the hopes that we get the end game
that's going to be a win with that pawn
it's not a win it's just a draw because
as long as the king is in front of a
pawn
those who know their king and pawn
opposition theory know that this is a
foregone conclusion black is going to
keep the king in front of the pawn
and eventually achieve equality by going
straight back
and then meeting white with opposition
and forcing stalemate
this is a theoretically known problem
with the game if you consider it a
problem and as of this moment
i kind of do right so again why did i
argue in my breakdown that i think
stalemate equaling a win
would do even more for human chess than
alpha zero this is one of the examples a
single pawn is now
always a win not just this pawn but a
corner pawn
is also a win because of stalemate
equaling a win
right that would allow everything about
the earlier stages of the game how we
evaluate and assess those critical
moments
between magnus carlsen and cara nakamura
as having even more weight
because of that one pesh advantage
finally being enough
here's my second example for stalemate
equaling a win talk about an advantage
you wish you could convert you got king
and queen versus king and pawn
but guess what this is not a win for
those who know their theory because
after queen to b3 check
black can play the move king to a1 this
is a well-known uh defensive trick
right you have to keep checking the king
forever because the moment you touch
that pawn
stalemate well guess what if stalemate
equals a win
that's no longer a problem right
obviously those defensive minded people
in the comments would be like
defense isn't a problem anyway obviously
i'm aware of that but i'm giving you an
example
of content that could lead to more
decisive results and i would argue again
at a human
level not just alpha zero versus alpha
zero this could be a super exciting
development right
the pressure it would add earlier in
games because you don't want to reach
the same game anymore you no longer get
to assess
the idea that you would actually be able
to hold a draw and
rob all the fans of that decisive result
they want with the biggest issue we have
in the game of kings
that a draw is different than other
sports it goes away
this is now a win for white because that
trick doesn't work and for those who
don't know the trap the moment the king
goes in front of the pawn
now your king can come forward right you
give checks eventually you force the
king back in front this is very typical
when the king's in front
you do it again you rinse and repeat
eventually checkmate it's only the idea
of the stalemate that allows this end
game to be a draw
but again as we see maybe that's no
longer a problem if stalemate equals a
win
next position this is a funny one
because it actually
changes the fact not that zugzwang needs
to exist because ziggs wong is still a
thing
in a position where if someone could say
pass it would be a draw that would be
more a draw by agreement
i almost would equate it to draw by
repetition or 50 moves zug's long is
needed
to force someone to move when it's their
turn right in order for us to be able to
win end games that otherwise would not
be winning if the turn didn't have to
pass in chess
but this particular position right here
is actually
normally a draw because in this check
the defensive technique is based around
stalemate
the fact that white can't just wait here
because any move
is a draw the king and bishop no longer
have squares that's a very confusing
concept for beginners to understand
you have to trap the king in order to
checkmate just like the king is trapped
here
the king has no moves when he's
checkmated just like the king has no
moves here
surrounded by enemy pieces often just
like here right but no this is a draw
the other ones are a win again it would
be very interesting to see what human
beings would have to do differently
right you couldn't even defend this
engine anymore by relying on the
stalemate in the corner you'd have to
defend it with the king and the bishop
out in the wild right and what would
that look like i don't even i don't even
know what it would look like would this
endgame still even be a draw if you
weren't able to rely
on the stalemate opposite color corner
of your particular bishop
i don't know but it would be a lot of
fun to find out right my next position
number four
talk about an end game that i've talked
about with grand master robert hess on
every show we ever do
where grand masters are very smart and
strategic about
defensing defending otherwise lost
positions by the fact that if you're in
an
opposite color corner of the enemy
bishop it's a draw
this is a stalemate despite the fact
that white is up both
bishop and pawn well what if that wasn't
the case
what if you can move forward and no
longer fear a move
like bishop to f4 but rather embrace it
and win the game by stalemate right
again
it's not even just about this position
here it would affect positions earlier
in terms of the level of play we'd have
to see finding new ways to maybe get a
repetition in a draw
right the draw could still exist based
on
the the idea that if you can check
forever or like we say get down to just
king and king right
but there's no way that it doesn't
increase a lot of decisive results and
add a lot of fun to how we're evaluating
more complicated positions case in point
how would we handle end games like this
where the fact that black played queen
h2 check is normally
perfectly fine for a draw right because
as we already assessed earlier a pawn in
front of the king is an easily drawn
king upon ending right
not if stalemate equals a win here white
could play queen e2 check
a cross fire defensive and aggressive
move that
punches us into the king and pawn ending
where suddenly white is winning
with a pawn that normally would not be
enough
right that would mean queen h2 check is
not a move that black could afford
having to rely on different diagonal
checks and trying to find more creative
ways
to keep the game alive and keep the fans
and viewers happy
now one of my last examples that i
believe is truly applicable at the very
high levels
is rook endings so many rook endings are
drawn
literally it is the pop culture phrase
of whatever
russian grand master said it long ago
all rook endings are drawn i apologize
for forgetting my chess quotes for a
second but it's been a long day and this
is like the fifth video i'm recording
but you've heard the thing all work
endings are drawn
well this particular rook ending is a
draw because
even though white has the king cut off
because the pawn is far advanced enough
this is known as a frontal attack the
frontal attack
is a draw for black because you were
able to keep pressure on the pawn and
then finally when your king touched down
on e8
the rook can go to e8 and in a king and
pawn ending
this is an easy draw again because the
pawn is too advanced in front of the
king
you simply use distant opposition
waiting for the king to come forward you
just wait on the eighth rank and the
moment he does
you grab the opposition and you're going
to hold this draw
as long as you know basic king and pawn
defensive principles
but what if rookie 8 wasn't a
possibility how do we assess this engine
suddenly we're looking at a rook ending
that's a theoretically known draw as
actually a win for white moves like rook
c8 are too slow the frontal attack
defense here fails
when rookie 8 is off the table because
the longer you sit
eventually okay we've already looked at
rookie being bad eventually
we'll throw it the white king comes up
you check forever
i have a lot of videos on this end game
over on chess.com which would become
irrelevant
if stalemate was a win right i'd have to
redo all my videos over their chess.com
another good reason to do this right
for everyone who hates those videos the
point is eventually you check that you
get up the board and the rook has to go
back
i.e the frontal attack and the moment he
does now the rook can come up
next move you attack the rook you attack
the rook and you start advancing and the
black king
is just too far away the pawn and king
outplay the rook this is known
as the frontal attack often it can be a
defensive measure that works
but in this particular position it
wouldn't because
black loses the advantage he has that
the king is protecting the idea of
breaking the white rook's control
right this defensive idea goes out the
window and how many
other rook ending defensive ideas might
go out the window with it i have no idea
all i know is
stalemate equaling a win would be
something that could change the way
we we think about chess we talk about
chess we present chess to new beginners
and allow them to get
the concepts of trapping an enemy king
much faster
and even at the high levels might really
add entertainment and our different
viewpoint
to how we look at all kinds of defensive
technique how we how we really emphasize
smaller advantages earlier now that we
know we can't just hold with stalemate
i get excited about the possibilities
and i hope you do too leave a comment
down below
don't leave me down leave a comment give
me a like come on we've worked hard with
this give us a share tell your friends
about me and these thesechest.com videos
and
again i can't wait to hear your thoughts
about whether i'm totally crazy for
ranking stalemate
equals a win above classical chess or
whether you just might
you might hate yourself a little bit for
it but you might actually agree with me
on this one either way we will see you
around on chess.com
and i can't wait to hear your thoughts